ah the Creator man of the year take one
hello i'm tyler here and the title of
what i'm gonna be doing is right there
so you already know that i'm about to do
for the next two minutes favorite ride
at Six Flags favorite sushi roll from
Miss Tracee Ellis Ross I love that woman
she's awesome Colossus is the greatest
ride ever
especially the new one [ __ ] is cute as
[ __ ] and I prefer just salmon over rice
no wasabi with ill sauce I'm not in the
rolls with the cucumber and all that
extra garnish [ __ ] not for me Seth
Rogen asked what were your favorite
movies growing up I don't remember but I
could tell you my favorite movies now
Napoleon Dynamite super bad 20th century
woman scary movie - Spike Jonze why did
you win Man of the Year I don't know
because I'm tight as [ __ ] I do a lot of
tight [ __ ] like that's really sick and
I'm cute from Kendall Jenner that's the
bro you're the most fun person to be
around and genuinely one of my favorite
people I just want to know when you go
home at the end of the day and sit with
yourself
how does it feel what do you think
sleep I don't know how it feels I go
home and like but I don't know what she
wanted the answer to be like oh it feels
like I could change the world in like
the children sleep she thought she had
one Christmas ad Andriy if you are
unfamiliar with that name Despicable Me
a bunch of other tight-ass [ __ ]
just know that illumination google it oh
that's a long question okay Chris we
live in a world that is more fixated
than ever on how people perceive us and
yet your artistic expression across
music fashion performance and business
appears to be so inner directed where
did you get all of this confidence and
can you share some of it I don't know
where I got this confidence from I just
have it and I can't you physically can't
share confidence it comes from within
and if you don't have it they don't have
it and that's their problem I like
myself I with myself and I do everything
that I do to please myself and I think
Chris has some of that too because that
is one confident I like him and he just
asked another question what was the
first song you fell in love with maybe
sometimes dancing by brownstone it's off
their first album I think it's number
five or um couldn't love you more by
Shaddai off love deluxe um that's number
three or like some of my faith Evans
first album or like John Hayes for it
was like a I remember being like four or
five and just coming across all those
albums and like that she really shaped
like my ear for sound
and I still to this day trying to mimic
just how some of those beats were made
so yeah that stuff Jerrod Carmichael
that's my [ __ ] big homie and he said
this is a good question
Wow would you rather never hear rolling
them sevens again or get another foot
massage that is a good question because
rolling them sevens is a song by any Rd
of their last album that I absolutely
love I want to get it tatted on my leg
and I prefer a foot massage over a block
I've had a foot thing since I was a
little boy I don't know what it is oh do
what
probably never here rolling them sevens
ever again and I love that song have you
ever gotten a real foot massage like a
real one no like from like a someone
that grabs your feet like you've been
eating too much fish type [ __ ] crazy
I'll be getting from massages I like any
areas you want like that's your and I'm
like oh I've been biking my feet hurt
but also my back my back don't hurt I
just don't want to look weird and just
be the only Guinness foot touch for hour
and 30 minutes bro okay Pharrell
Williams axed as you are inspiring
others with your unique point of view
and game-changing feats what are the
amazing ways you possibly pay all this
forward oh okay I just did a bike where
SC bikes and I wasn't fixated on even
selling them I kind of just wanted to
give them to a bunch of kids who
couldn't get bike so I actually teamed
up with our Boys and Girls Club to like
I just sent like 10 that each one that I
could with a lot of the bikes that we
had and they'll just give them away to
kids who want a bike I guess that counts